bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono mal digerita ci siamo tornati
dopo non mi ricordo quando è l'ultima
volta che l'ho fatto di preciso siamo
tornati su svendere ragazzi perché hanno
fatto hanno fatto slider
all anzi editore bender ansia che non
capisco il perché di questo nome ma
posso immaginarlo cioè il fatto che si
chiama slider ansie ti è una cosa
stupenda comunque la cosa che volevo
dire che è una demo non è ancora gioco
ufficiale però siccome è stato buttato
in un modo assurdo te ed è un botto e
non faccio sto render vorrei provare a
vedere se riesco a fare qualcosa a sé
javadi perfetto si sa come cazzo siamo
arrivati qui ma questo già lo sappiamo
questo questo è oramai siamo abituati a
saperlo interi potrà anche scappare
perché sono più basso della recinzione
ma no invece si sono passato a posto ho
vinto ho vinto sarà sono scappato a
prescindere c'è veramente io io milano
ci sarei non ci sarei dovuto passare
dichiari house un secondo un po tutto
secondo di gioco ci ho trovato un bug e
bellissimo sono riuscita a uscire
ragazzi cè un precipizio della madonna e
c'è un panorama alla massa grafica in 4k
full hd dove la mettiamo non sa bene che
io io non so fare
sono l'unica cazzo di persona al mondo
in grado di trovare un pug dei primi
secondi di gioco bellissimo questo se
questo effettivamente un burrone
oppure se non c'e la tecno è un burrone
perché come non detto che è in partenza
con le contro biglie voi ragazzi fate
finta di non aver visto coi primi
secondi di video perché lascia lungo già
trovato un bug fantastico lasciarlo
perdere con la parte ii bellissima cosa
ci ha scritto vino visto cantieri in
costruzione perfetto non sappiamo
ragazzi come siamo arrivati qui questo
lo sapete già
ma sappiamo che c'è una torre dalla
parte opposta questo ampia sicuro non
penso che non gioca sanderson tipo quasi
un anno forse non vorrei è una cagata ho
voluto riprovarci ragazzi prevedere come
c'è portone un pochettino e vecchi tempi
perché non mi ricordo più quali sono le
sensazioni a giocare a questi giochi
splendidi modà così mi ricorda che
perché che casa in store o perché c'è
una macchina della polizia tra ato
io vorrei sapere un attimino cocoon cosa
sta domando perché non credo abbia una
telecamera siccome la torcia la tiene
così che è un po scomodo ma va beh non
capisco cosa sta registrando ho già una
telecamera sullo stomaco come corsa va
beh non importa ragazzi e forse quando
non ho trovato una pagina finora sono
diventato scarsi si aprono le porte non
sia pronta seriamente fatemi capire ma
come jet
cosa ci fa un jet non ho trovato un
pozzo della una macchina della polizia
dei boiler dunque questo che non so cosa
sia e un jet un cazzo di getta una luce
una luce o è un lampione o sono morto
una delle due hanno è un lampione
perfetto sì ne ho trovata lo trovo
troppo trovato una cazzo di pagina su 8
bellissimo ho sentito tra l'altro c'è un
rumore di fondo che è iniziato a caldo
senza che io prendessi nulla gravissime
che hanno mai visto non ha visto ma
visto mai visto ma visto messo o ma che
è bello che se le tue mani sexy non me
le posso scordare voldemort
[Musica]
ma evolve molto lo sapevo lo sapevo che
scaricandolo di carlo vuole di calma ho
detto calmo ea un attimo cazzo è ok
regola numero uno non si scherza con
boldi assolutamente se si riuscisse a
trovare una cazzo di fatto che a
mezz'ora non ci fosse 16 56 dc cazzo di
minuti per trovarne una che io non ho
parole
ma certo non l'accetto non accetto via
via via via non l'accetto non l'accetto
non accedono l'accento non l'accetto non
lascia però mai a [ __ ] devi morire e
devi morire e devi morire solo vivo non
so come spiega non so non fate domande
non lo so c'è qualcosa che va a fuoco
probabilmente il mio culo anche quello
che si è rovesciato il cestino cribbio
fermi un attimo che se fermi un attimo
richiamato ma quello è splendido e di
glera un bastone infuocato vi prego
bastoni per agevolare lega allora kakà
mi ami lega ce la posso fare le faccio
questo non c'è il fuoco
giorgio al fuoco l'unico stronzo pasto
deficit un'altra pagina 22 e record e
record mondiale quel nessuno ci è mai
arrivato a due sicuro voglio capire un
secondo me dove mi devo riposare un
secondo perché sto deficiente già non
corre più e lì seduto più e più volte
che i personaggi is lander meno la
stessa resistenza di uno che mangia al
mcdonald per la stessa
lo sa ci avrei scommesso qualsiasi cosa
lurido presente ci sono delle statue
arco anton bellissime però ecco perché
c'è la pagina si troverà prima o dopo
scommetto che è più prima che dopo però
vabbè avevo lo senti potente già dovessi
morire con un cazzo fosse l'ultima cosa
che faccio nella mia vita non mi tirerò
mai sta roba lì non ho capito dentro
benocci di velocci non celate sintomi e
tattica di sigarette slang e cioè anche
se toseland non puoi entrare se non puoi
trarre lega perché to bottle sfera
supera il soffitto in teoria non
dovrebbe fare quindi sono sicuro ma
dentro credo di sì anche se larga non
capivo un difetto ci sono degli spazi
laga surdich e blu che lo tra lo
stratega lo trovate a farmi fare inferi
che ce lo fermi che sono fermi che c'è
sono vivo sono vivo non fate domande non
dovete neanche chiedermi come sia
possibile perché non lo so non c'è non
c'è ok canicani che ci siamo capite ci
siamo si è pronto di merda 22 siamo
fregati
no no cazzo cazzo quanto stavo no non ce
la farò mai ritornare come prima non ce
la farò mai più
ve la fate a trovare una lurida pagina
qui maledizione no perché sono solamente
sei uno sbronzo sei uno stronzo
no non ho torto ma neanche devo stare su
una pagina ragazzi c'è una parte devi
toglierti la sega sulla parità signor
voldemort
nell'isola la bacchetta di sambuco che
ho trovato l'altro giorno non 26
perché se il tuo rumori ma non vedo
nessuno visto il tecnico pinto
vito giu la merda non sono neanche morto
non sono mai possiamo lanciato il mouse
ma sono ancora vivo non si sa com io
torno all'inizio doveroso davvero prima
e esco dal buco dove sono entrati che fu
così cool operare che non so non so come
ho fatto a non prendermi non me lo
chiedete non ne ho idea
lo vedo leggermente vi incassato adesso
di prima non ho capito bene con come mai
unita sul sì c'è una pagina non ci credo
negazione trovo tutte prima di trovare
una sega alle sole proposte fantastico
3d 8 non chiedetemi come ho fatto
non chiedetevi come mai ci aveva la
testa in mezzo alla roma non importa
roberto kobeh dove non lo vedo cazzo
governo lo vedo ragazzi non lo quando
non lo vedo è peggio e non so dovete
volte non lo vedo dove no no no no no
non vado nelle tende visto che lui atto
qualcosa come tre o quattro metri magari
non c entra e posso starmene lì dentro
finché non muoio cosa molto molto
semplice non amati mi sta seguendo
quindi meglio che mi muovo il prima
possibile allora si sta come d'autunno
agli alberi cowes lander devo trovare
una lanciare un ramo di fuoco
come non detto no perché io metto le
idee poi lui si mette in mezzo di
lasciar perdere dove poi c'era una
pagina una volta l'ho persa prefetto la
vedo ragazzi devi stare fermo però dove
per caso
ok bene così merlo presa l'ha presa
presa quattro gli otto perché ce la
posso fare
ma magari se cantori nuovo no
scherzavano dagli di risparmio mostrando
abbassa mi chiama e stordito grazie
grazie grazie mille non ti ho neanche
non so neanche dove era non l'ho neanche
visto mamma ma spaccato un timpano da
cloud ragazzi ho capito che è infatti b
le uniche a cosa che si può fare e come
si partì uscire dal costo di dietro come
ho fatto all'inizio perché è l'unico
modo per vincere quello da casarini
direi che per oggi bastos lander per chi
arriva neanche tanto a ritornare in una
foresta così ma l'ho fatto non si sa
perché i ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
come al solito verso documento mi piace
anche a poesia di facebook e come la
novità trovate nella descrizione seriosi
dovresti destinazioni ci vediamo nel
prossimo video belle ragazze